The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
guys, let's get started.
So today, we're going to
talk about network security.
And in particular,
we're going to talk
about this paper on TCP/IP
security by this guy
Steve Bellovin, who used to be
at AT&T and now is at Columbia.
One interesting thing
about this paper
is it's actually a
relatively old paper.
It's more than 10 years old.
And in fact, it's
commentary on a paper
that was 10 years before that.
And many of you guys actually
ask, why are we reading this
if many of these problems have
been solved in today's TCP
protocol stacks?
So one interesting
point-- so it's
true that some of these
problems that Steve
describes in this paper
have been solved since then.
Some of them are still
actually problems today.
We'll sort of look at that
and see what's going on.
But you might actually
wonder, why didn't people
solve all these problems
in the first place
when they were designing TCP?
What were they thinking?
And it's actually not clear.
So what do you guys think?
Why wasn't TCP designed
to be secure with all
these considerations up front?
Yeah, any guesses?
All right, anyone else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The internet was
a much more trusting place
back then.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
was almost literally
a quote from this guy's paper.
Yeah, at the time-- the whole
internet set of protocols
was designed I guess
about 40 years ago now.
The requirements were
totally different.
It was to connect a bunch
of relatively trusting sites
that all knew each
other by name.
And I think this is often
the case in any system that
becomes successful.
The requirements change.
So it used to be that
this was a protocol
for a small number of sites.
Now it's the entire world.
And you don't know
all the people
connected to the
internet by name anymore.
You can't call them
up on the phone
if they do something
bad, et cetera.
So I think this is a story
for many of the protocols
we look at.
And many of you guys have
questions, like, what the hell
were these guys thinking?
This is so broken.
But in fact, they were designing
a totally different system.
It got adopted.
Same for the web,
like we were looking
at in the last couple of weeks.
It was designed for a
very different goal.
And it expanded.
And you sort of have
these growing pains
you have to figure out how
to make the protocol adapt
to new requirements.
And another thing that
somewhat suddenly happened
is I think people
also in the process
gained a much
greater appreciation
for the kinds of
problems you have
to worry about in security.
And it used to be the case
that you didn't really
understand all the
things that you
should worry about an
attacker doing to your system.
And I think it's
partly for this reason
that it's sort of
interesting to look
at what happened to TCP
security, what went wrong,
how could we fix it, et
cetera, to both figure out
what kinds of problems you might
want to avoid when designing
your own protocols,
and also what's
the right mindset for thinking
about these kinds of attacks.
How do you figure out
what an attacker might
be able to do in
your own protocol
when you're designing it so
you can avoid similar pitfalls?
All right, so with
that preamble aside,
let's actually start talking
about what the paper is about.
So how should we think
about security in a network?
So I guess we could try to
start from first principles
and try to figure out,
what is our threat model?
So what do we think
the attacker is
going to be able to
do in our network?
Well, relatively
straightforwardly,
there's presumably being
able to intercept packets,
and probably being
able to modify them.
So if you send a packet
over the network,
it might be prudent to assume
that some bad guy out there is
going to see your packet and
might be able to change it
before it reaches
the destination,
might be able to drop
it, and in fact might
be able to inject
packets of their own
that you never sent
with arbitrary contents.
And probably-- so
this you can sort of
come up with fairly
straightforwardly by just
thinking, well, if you
don't trust the network,
some bad guy is going to
send arbitrary packets,
see yours, modify
them, et cetera.
Somewhat more worryingly,
as this paper talks about,
the bad guy can also
participate in your protocols.
They have their
own machine, right?
So the attacker has
their own computer
that they have
full control over.
So even if all the
computers that you trust
are reasonably maintained,
they all behave correctly,
the bad guy has his own
computer that he can
make it do whatever he wants.
And in fact, he can
participate in a protocol
or distribute a system.
So if you have a
routing protocol, which
involves many people talking
to each other, at some scale,
it's probably going to
be impractical to keep
the bad guys out.
If you're running a routing
protocol with 10 participants,
then maybe you can just call
all them up and say, well, yeah,
yeah, I know all you guys.
But at the scale of the
internet today, it's
unfeasible to have sort of
direct knowledge of what
everyone else or who everyone
else in this protocol is.
So probably some
bad guy is going
to be participating in your
protocols or distributed
systems.
And it's important to design
distributed systems that
can nonetheless do something
reasonable with that.
All right, so what
are the implications
of all these things?
I guess we'll go down the list.
So intercepting is-- it's on
the whole easy to understand.
Well, you shouldn't
send any important data
over the network if you expect
a bad guy to intercept them,
or at least not in clear text.
Maybe you should
encrypt your data.
So that seems relatively
straightforward to sort
of figure out.
Although still you should sort
of keep it in mind, of course,
when designing protocols.
Now, injecting packets
turns out to lead
to a much wider range
of interesting problems
that this paper talks about.
And in particular,
attackers can inject
packets that can pretend to
be from any other sender.
Because the way this works in
IP is that the IP packet itself
has a header that contains
the source of the packet
and the destination.
And it's up to whoever
creates the packet
to fill in the right values
for the source and destination.
And no one checks that
the source is necessarily
the correct.
There's some filtering
going on these days.
But it's sort of fairly spotty,
and it's hard to rely on.
So to a first
approximation, an attacker
could fill in any IP
address as the source,
and it will get to the
destination correctly.
And it's interesting
to try to figure out
what could an attacker do with
such a capability of sending
arbitrary packets.
Now, in the several
weeks up to this,
like in buffer overflows
and web security,
we looked at, to a large extent,
implementation bugs, like,
how could you exploit
a buffer overflow?
And interestingly, the
author of this paper
is actually not at all
interested in implementation
bugs.
He's really interested in
protocol errors or protocol
mistakes.
So what's the big deal?
Why is he down on
implementation bugs,
even though we spent several
weeks looking at them?
Why does it matter?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because we have to
keep those bugs [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this is the
really big bummer about a bug
in your protocol design.
Because it's hard to change.
So if you have an
implementation bug,
well, you had a
memcpy or a print-out
out of some sort that
didn't check the range.
OK, well, you had a range
check, and it still works,
and now it's also secure.
So that's great.
But if you have some bug in
the protocol specification,
in how the protocol has
to work, then fixing a bug
is going to require
fixing a protocol, which
means potentially affecting
all the systems that
are out there speaking
this protocol.
So if we find some
problem in TCP,
it's potentially
quite devastating.
Because every machine that uses
TCP is going to have to change.
Because it's going
to be hard to make
it potentially
backwards compatible.
We'll see exactly
what these bugs are.
But this is the real reason
he's so excited about looking
at protocol bugs.
Because they're fairly
fundamental to the TCP protocol
that everyone agrees to speak.
So let's look at
one of these guys.
So the first example
he points out
has to do with how TCP
sequence numbers work.
So just to re-explain--
yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious.
This is a tiny bit off topic.
But let's say you do
find a bug in TCP.
How do you make
the change to it?
How do you tell
all the computers
in the world to change that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
it's a huge problem.
What if you find a bug in TCP?
Well, it's unclear what to do.
And I think the authors here
struggle a lot with that.
And in many ways, if
you could redesign TCP,
many of these bugs
are relatively
easy to fix if you knew what
to look for ahead of time.
But because TCP is
sort of relatively hard
to fix or change,
what ends up happening
is that people or
designers try to look
for backwards compatible
tweaks that either allow
old implementations to coexist
with the new implementation
or to add some optional field
that if it's there, then
the communication is
more secure in some way.
But it is a big problem.
If it's some security issue
that's deeply ingrained in TCP,
then it's going to be a pretty
humongous issue for everyone
to just pack up and move onto a
TCP version whatever, n plus 1.
And you can look at IPv6 as one
example of this not happening.
We've known this problem
was going to come up
for like 15 years or 20 years.
IPv6 has been around for
well over 10 years now.
And it's just hard to convince
people to move away from IPv4.
It's good enough.
It sort of works.
It's a lot of
overhead to move over.
And no one else is
speaking IPv6, so
why should I start speaking
this bizarre protocol
that no one else is
going to speak to me in?
So it's sort of moving along.
But I think it
takes a long time.
And there's going to be really
some motivation to migrate.
And backwards
compatibility helps a lot.
Not good enough for,
I guess, IPv6-- IPv6
has lots of backwards
compatibility plans in it.
You can talk to an
IPv4 host from IPv6.
So they try to engineer
all this support.
But still, it's hard to
convince people to upgrade.
All right, but yeah, looking
back at the TCP sequence
numbers, we're going to look
at actually two problems that
have to do with how the
TCP handshake works.
So let's just spend a little
bit of time working out
what are the details of how a
TCP connection gets initially
established.
So there's actually
three packets
that have to get sent in
order for a new TCP connection
to be established.
So our client generates a
packet to connect to a server.
And it says, well, here's
my IP address, C, client.
I'm sending this to the server.
And there's various fields.
But the ones that are
interesting for the purpose
of this discussion is going
to be a sequence number.
So there's going to
be a syn flag saying,
I want to synchronize state
and establish a new connection.
And you include a
client sequence number
in the initial syn packet.
Then when the server
receives this,
the server is going
to look and say,
well, a client wants
to connect to me,
so I'll send a packet
back to whatever
this address is,
whoever said they're
trying to connect to me.
So it'll send a packet from
the server to the client
and include its own
synchronization number, SN
server.
And it'll acknowledge
the client's number.
And finally, the
client replies back,
acknowledging the
server synchronization
number-- acknowledge SNS.
And now the client can
actually start sending data.
So in order to send
data, the client
has to include some
data in the packet,
and also put in the sequence
number of the client
to indicate that
this is actually
sort of legitimate client data
at the start of the connection.
It's not some data
from later on,
for example, that just
happens to arrive now
because the server missed some
initial parts of the data.
So generally, all
these sequence numbers
were meant for ensuring in
order delivery of packets.
So if the client sends
two packets, the one that
has the initial sequence number,
that's the first chunk of data.
And the one with the
next sequence number
is the next chunk of data.
But it turns out to also
be useful for providing
some security properties.
Here's an example of these
requirements changing.
So initially, no
one was thinking
TCP provides any
security properties.
But then applications
started using TCP and sort
of relying on these
TCP connections
not being able to be broken
by some arbitrary attacker,
or an attacker not being able to
inject data into your existing
TCP connection.
And all of a sudden, this
mechanism that was initially
meant for just
packet ordering now
gets used to guarantee
some semblance of security
for these connections.
So in this case, I
guess the problem
stems from what could a
server assume about this TCP
connection.
So typically, the server
assumes-- implicitly,
you might imagine-- that this
connection is established
with the right client at
this IP address C. It seems
like a natural thing to assume.
Is there any basis for
making this assumption?
If a server gets this
message saying, here's
some data on this connection
from a client to a server,
and it has sequence number
C, why might the server
conclude that this was actually
the real client sending this?
AUDIENCE: Because the sequence
number is hard to guess.
PROFESSOR: Right, so that's sort
of the implicit thing going on,
that it has to have the
right sequence number C here.
And in order for this
connection to get established,
the client must have
acknowledged the server
sequence number S here.
And the server sequence number
S was only sent by the server
to the intended
client IP address.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How many bits are
available for the sequence
number?
PROFESSOR: So sequence numbers
in TCP are 32 bits long.
That's not entirely
easy to guess.
If it was really a
random 32 bit number,
it would be hard to just guess.
And you'd probably
waste a lot of bandwidth
trying to guess this.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: The data
frequency number
is higher than the
initial sequence number?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so basically,
these things get incremented.
So every time you
send a syn, that
counts as one byte against
your sequence number.
So this is SNC.
I think actually what happens
is this is SNC plus 1.
And then it goes on from there.
So if you send 5 bytes, then the
next one is SNC initial plus 6.
So this just counts the
bytes that you're sending.
SYNs count as 1 byte each.
Make sense?
Other questions about this?
All right, so typically,
or at least the way
the TCP specification
recommended
that people choose
these sequence numbers,
was to increment them at
some roughly fixed rate.
So the initial RFCs suggested
that you increment these things
at something like 250,000
units, plus 250,000, per second.
And the reason that it
wasn't entirely random
is that these sequence
numbers are actually
used to prevent out of
order packets, or packets
from previous connections,
from interfering
with new connections.
So if every time you
established a new connection
you chose a completely
random sequence number,
then there's some chance if you
establish lots of connections
over and over that some packet
from a previous connection
is going to have a
similar enough sequence
number to your new
connection and is
going to be accepted as
a valid piece of data
on that new connection.
So this is something that the
TCP designers worried a lot
about-- these out of order
packets or delayed packets.
So as a result, they really
wanted these sequence numbers
to progress in a roughly
monotonic matter over time,
even across connections.
If I opened one
connection, it might
have the same source and
destination, port numbers,
IP addresses, et cetera.
But because I established
this connection now instead
of earlier, packets
from earlier hopefully
aren't going to match up
with the sequence numbers
I have for my new connection.
So this was a mechanism
to prevent confusion
across repeated
connection establishments.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you don't know
exactly how much your other
grid that you're talking to is
going to improve the sequencing
pack, how do you know that
the packet you're getting is
the next packet if there wasn't
[INAUDIBLE] immediate packet
that you--
PROFESSOR: So typically you'll
remember the last packet
that you received.
And if the next sequence
number is exactly that,
then this is the next
packet in sequence.
So for example, here,
the server knows
that I've seen exactly
SNC plus 1 worth of data.
If the next packet has
sequence number SNC plus 1,
that's the next one.
AUDIENCE: So you're
saying that when
you establish a sequence number,
then even after that you're
committing it--
PROFESSOR: Well,
absolutely, yeah, yeah.
So these sequence
numbers, initially when
you establish it, they get
picked according to some plan.
We'll talk about that plan.
You can sort of think
they might be random.
But over time, they have to have
some flow for initial sequence
numbers for connection.
But within a connection, once
they're established, that's it.
They're fixed.
And they just tick
along as the data
gets sent on the
connection, exactly.
Make sense?
All right, so there
were some plans
suggested for how to manage
these sequence numbers.
And it was actually
a reasonable plan
for avoiding duplicate packets
in the network causing trouble.
But the problem, of
course, showed up
that attackers were able to
sort of guess these sequence
numbers.
Because there wasn't a lot
of randomness being chosen.
So the way that the host machine
would choose these sequence
numbers is they have just a
running counter in memory.
Every second they
bump it by 250,000.
And every time a
new connection comes
in, they also bump it by some
constant like 64k or 128k.
I forget the exact number.
So this was relatively easy
to guess, as you can tell.
You send them their
connection request,
and you see what sequence
number comes back.
And then you know
the next one is going
to be 64k higher than that.
So there wasn't a huge amount
of randomness in this protocol.
So we can just sketch
out what this looks like.
So if I'm an attacker that
wants to connect to a server
but pretend to be from
a particular IP address,
then what I might do is send
a request to the server,
very much like the
first step there,
include some initial sequence
number that I choose.
At this point, any
sequence number
is just as good, because
the server shouldn't
have any assumptions about
what the client's sequence
number is.
Now, what does the server do?
The server gets the
same packet as before.
So it performs the
same way as before.
It sends a packet back to
the client with some server
sequence number and
acknowledges SNC.
And now the attacker,
if the attacker
wants to establish a connection,
needs to somehow synthesize
a packet that looks exactly like
the third packet over there.
So it needs to send a packet
from the client to the server.
That's easy enough.
You just fill in these
values in the header.
But you have to acknowledge
this server sequence number SNS.
And this is where sort
of the problems start.
If the SNS value is
relatively easy to guess,
then the attacker is good to go.
And now the server
thinks they have
an established connection with
a client coming from this IP
address.
And now an attacker could
inject data into this connection
just as before.
They just synthesize
a packet that
looks like this,
has the data, and it
has the client sequence number
that in fact the adversary
chose.
Maybe it's plus 1 here.
But it all hinges on being able
to guess this particular server
supplied sequence number.
All right, does this make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the reason
that the server sequence
number isn't completely random?
PROFESSOR: So
there's two reasons.
One, as I was
describing earlier,
the server wants to
make sure that packets
from different
connections over time
don't get confused
for one another.
So if you establish a
connection from one source port
to another destination port, and
then you close the connection
and establish another one of
the same source and destination
port, you want to make sure
the packets from one connection
don't appear to be valid
in another connection.
AUDIENCE: So the
server sequence number
is incremented for every
one of their packets?
PROFESSOR: Well, so the sequence
numbers within a connection,
as I was describing, get
bumped with all the data
in a connection.
But there's also
the question of,
how do you choose the
initial sequence number here?
And that gets bumped every
time a new connection is
established.
So the hope is that by the time
it wraps around 2 to the 32
and comes back, there's
been enough time
so that old packets
in the network
have actually been
dropped and will not
appear as duplicates anymore.
So that's the reason
why you don't just
choose random points,
or they didn't initially
choose random points.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So this is a
problem between connections,
for a connection between the
same guide, the same client,
the same server, the same source
port, the same destination.
And we're worried
about old packets--
PROFESSOR: So this is what the
original, yeah, TCP designers
were worried about,
which is why they
prescribed this way of picking
these initial sequence numbers.
AUDIENCE: If you have
different new connections,
you could differentiate.
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So then I don't see
why the incrementing stuff
and not just take randomly.
PROFESSOR: So I think the
reason they don't pick randomly
is that if you did pick
randomly, and you established,
I don't know, 1,000 connections
within a short amount
of time from the same source
to the same destination,
then, well, every one of them
is some random value of module 2
to the 32.
And now there's a
nontrivial chance
that some packet
from one connection
will be delayed in the network,
and eventually show up again,
and will get confused for a
packet from another connection.
This is just sort of
nothing to do with security.
This is just their
design consideration
initially for reliable delivery.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] some other
client to the server, right?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: This is [INAUDIBLE]
some other client?
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So we haven't actually said
why this is interesting at all
for the attacker to do.
Why bother?
You could just go from
his old IP address, right?
AUDIENCE: So what happens
for the server [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, this is actually
an interesting question.
What happens here?
So this packet doesn't
just get dropped.
It actually goes
to this computer.
And what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], they
just mentioned you try and do it
like they would
try and do it when
the other computer was
updating or rebooting or off,
or something.
PROFESSOR: Right,
certainly they felt, oh,
that computer is offline.
The packet will
just get dropped,
and you don't have to
worry about it too much.
If a computer is actually
listening on that IP address,
then in the TCP
protocol, you're supposed
to send a reset packet
resetting the connection.
Because this is not a connection
that computer C knows about.
And in TCP, this is presumed
to be because, oh, this
is some old packet that
I requested long ago,
but I've since
forgotten about it.
So the machine C here might send
a packet to the server saying,
I want a reset.
I actually forget exactly which
sequence number goes in there.
But the client C here knows
all the sequence numbers
and send any sequence
number as necessary
and reset this connection.
So if this computer C
is going to do this,
then it might interfere
with your plan
to establish a connection.
Because when S gets
this packet, it
says, oh, sure, if
you don't want it,
I'll reset your connection.
There's some
implementation-ish bugs
that you might exploit, or at
least the author talks about,
and an potentially
exploiting, that would prevent
client C from responding.
So for example, if you flood
C with lots of packets,
it's an easy way to get
him to drop this one.
It turns out there are other
more interesting bugs that
don't require flooding C with
lots of packets that still get
C to drop this
packet, or at least it
used to on some
implementations on TCP stacks.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Presumably,
most firewalls
would also [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This one?
AUDIENCE: No, the SYN.
PROFESSOR: This one.
AUDIENCE: That
came into a client,
and a client didn't originally
send a SYN to that server.
And the firewall is
going to drop it.
PROFESSOR: It depends, yeah.
So certainly if you have a very
sophisticated stateful firewall
that keeps track of all existing
connections, or for example
if you have a NAT,
then this might happen.
On the other hand, a NAT
might actually send the RST
on behalf of the client.
So it's not clear.
I think this is not as common.
So for example, on
a Comcast network,
I certainly don't have anyone
intercepting these packets
and maintaining state for me
and sending RSTs on my behalf
or anything like that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So why
can't the server
have independent
sequence numbers
for each possible source?
PROFESSOR: Right, so this is in
fact what TCP stacks do today.
This is one example of how you
fix this problem in a backwards
compatible manner.
So we'll get to
exactly the formulation
of how you arrange this.
But yeah, it turns out that
if you look at this carefully,
as you're doing, you don't need
to have this initial sequence
number be global.
You just scope it to every
source/destination pair.
And then you have all
the duplicate avoidance
properties we had before, and
you have some security as well.
So just to sort
of write this out
on the board of how
the attacker is getting
this initial sequence number,
the attacker would probably
just send a connection
from its own IP address
to the server saying, I want
to establish a new connection,
and the server would
send a response
back to the attacker containing
its own sequence number S.
And if the SNS for
this connection
and the SNS for this
connection are related,
then this is a problem.
But you're saying, let's
make them not related.
Because this is from
a different address.
Then this is not
a problem anymore.
You can't guess what
this SNS is going
to be based on this SNS
for a different connection.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you still
have a collision problem,
because you could
engage the 32 bits
by the addresses of your peers.
So you have a lot of ports
for each one of these.
So you still have
conflicting sequence numbers
for all of these connections
that you're getting, right?
PROFESSOR: So these
sequence numbers
are specific, as it
turns out, to an IP
address and a port number
source/destination duple.
So if it's different
ports, then they
don't interfere with
each other at all.
AUDIENCE: Oh, because
you're using the port--
PROFESSOR: That's right,
yeah, you also use
the port in this as well.
AUDIENCE: Because I
thought those ports--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the ports
are sort of below the sequence
numbers in some way
of thinking about it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: If the sequence
numbers are global,
then doesn't the
attacker [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good point.
So in fact, if the server
increments the sequence number
by, I don't know,
64k I think it is,
or it was, for every connection,
then, well, you connect.
And then maybe five
other people connect.
And then you have
to do this attack.
So to some extent, you're right,
this is a little troublesome.
On the other hand,
you could probably
arrange it for your packet
here to be delivered just
before this packet.
So if you send these
guys back to back,
then there's a good chance
they'll arrive at the server
back to back.
The server will get
this one, respond
with this sequence number.
It'll get the next
one, this one,
respond with the sequence
number right afterwards.
And then you know exactly what
to put in this third packet
in your sequence.
So I think this is
not a foolproof method
of connecting to a server.
There's some guessing involved.
But if you carefully
arrange your packets right,
then it's quite easy to
make the right guess.
Or maybe you try several
times, and you'll get lucky.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So even if
it's totally random,
and you have to guess
it, there are only
like 4 billion possibilities.
It's not a huge number, right?
I feel like in the
course of a year,
you should be able to
probably get through.
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah, so
you're absolutely right.
You shouldn't really be relying
on TCP to provide security
very strongly.
Because you're right, it's
only 4 billion guesses.
And you can probably
send that many packets
certainly within a day if you
have a fast enough connection.
So it's sort of an
interesting argument
we're having here in the
sense that at some level,
TCP is hopefully insecure.
Because it's only 32 bits.
There's no way we
could make it secure.
But I think many
applications rely on
it enough that not providing
any security at all
is so much of a nuisance that
it really becomes a problem.
But you're absolutely right.
In practice, you do want to
do some sort of encryption
on top of this that
will provide stronger
guarantees that no one
tampered with your data,
but where the keys are
more than 32 bits long.
It still turns out to be
useful to prevent people
from tampering with TCP
connections in most cases.
All right, other questions?
All right, so let's see
what actually goes wrong.
Why is it a bad
thing if people are
able to spoof TCP connections
from arbitrary addresses?
So one reason why this
is bad is if there
is any kind of
IP-based authorization.
So if some server decides
whether an operation is going
to be allowed or not based on
the IP address it comes from,
then this is
potentially going to be
a problem for an attacker
who spoofed connections
from an arbitrary
source address.
So one example where
this was a problem--
and it largely
isn't anymore-- is
this family of r commands,
things like rlogin.
So it used to be the case
that you could run something
like rlogin into a
machine, let's say
athena.dialup.mit.edu.
And if your connection was
coming from a host at MIT,
then this rlogin command would
succeed if you say, oh yeah,
I'm user Alice on this machine.
Let me log in as user Alice
onto this other machine.
And it'll just trust that
all the machines at mit.edu
are trustworthy to
make these statements.
I should say I think
dial-up never actually
had this problem.
It was using Cerberus
from the very beginning.
But other systems certainly
did have such problems.
And this is an example of
using the IP address where
the connection is coming from
some sort of authentication
mechanism for whether
the caller or the client
is trustworthy or not.
So this certainly
used to be a problem,
isn't a problem anymore.
So relying on IP seems like
such a clearly bad plan.
Yet, this actually
is still the case.
So rlogin is gone.
It was recently replaced
by SSH now, which is good.
On the other hand,
there are still
many other examples
of protocols that rely
on IP-based authentication.
One of them is SMTP.
So when you send email, you
use SMTP to talk to some mail
server to send a message.
And to prevent spam,
many SMTP servers
will only accept
incoming messages
from a particular
source IP address.
So for example,
Comcast's mail server
will only accept mail
from Comcast IP addresses.
Same for MIT mail servers--
will only accept mail
from MIT IP addresses.
Or there was at least
one server that ISNT
runs that has this property.
So this is the case
where it's still
using IP-based authentication.
Here it's not so bad.
Worst case, you'll
send some piece of spam
through the mail server.
So that's probably why
they're still using it,
whereas things that allow you
to log into an arbitrary account
stopped using IP-based
authentication.
So does this make sense,
why this is a bad plan?
And just to double check,
suppose that some server
was using rlogin.
What would you do to attack it?
What bad thing would happen?
Suggestions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just getting
into your computer,
and then make a user that
you want to log into,
and then you get
into the network.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so basically
you get your computer.
You synthesize this data to look
like a legitimate set of rlogin
commands that say,
log in as this user
and run this command
in my Unix shell there.
You sort of synthesize this data
and you mount this whole attack
and send this data as if a
legitimate user was interacting
with an rlogin client, and
then you're good to go.
OK, so this is one
reason why you probably
don't want your TCP sequence
numbers to be so guessable.
Another problem is
these reset attacks.
So much like we were able
to send a SYN packet,
if you know someone's
sequence number,
you could also send
a reset packet.
We sort of briefly
talked about it
here as the legitimate
client potentially
sending a reset to reset
the fake connection
that the attacker
is establishing.
But in a similar
vain, the adversary
could try to send reset packets
for an existing connection
if there's some way
that the adversary knows
what your sequence number
is on that connection.
So this is actually not clear
if this is such a big problem
or or.
At some level,
maybe you should be
assuming that all your
TCP connections could
be broken at any time anyway.
It's not like the
network is reliable.
So maybe you should be expecting
your connections to drop.
But one place where
this turned out
to be particularly not a
good assumption to make
is in the case of routers
talking to one another.
So if you have
multiple routers that
speak some routing
protocol, then they're
connected, of course,
by some physical links.
But over some physical
links, they actually
speak some network protocol.
And that network
protocol runs over TCP.
So there's actually
some TCP session
running over each of
these physical links
that the routers use to
exchange routing information.
So this is certainly the
case for this protocol
called BGP we'll talk about
a bit more in a second.
And BGP uses the fact
that the TCP connection
is alive to also infer
that the link is alive.
So if the TCP connection
breaks, then the routers
assume the link broke.
And they recompute all
their routing tables.
So if an adversary
wants to mount
some sort of a denial
of service attack here,
they could try to
guess the sequence
numbers of these routers
and reset these sessions.
So if the TCP session between
two routers goes down,
both routers are like,
oh, this link is dead.
We have to recompute
all the routing tables,
and the routes change.
And then you might shoot
down another link, and so on.
So this is a bit of
a worrisome attack,
not because it violates
someone's secrecy, et cetera,
or at least not directly,
but more because it really
causes a lot of
availability problems
for other users in the system.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're an attacker,
and you wanted to target
one particular user,
could you just keep
sending connection requests
to a server on behalf
of his IP and make
him keep dropping
his connections
to the servers and so
you just [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, so it
requires you guessing.
So you're saying,
suppose I'm using Gmail,
and you want to stop me from
learning something in Gmail,
so just send packets
to my machine
pretending to be from Gmail.
Well, you have to guess the
right source and destination
port numbers.
The destination port
number is probably 443,
because I'm using HTTPS.
But the source port
number is going
to be some random 16-bit thing.
And it's also going to be the
case that probably the sequence
numbers are going
to be different.
So unless you guess a
sequence number that's
within my TCP window, which
is in order of probably
tens of kilobytes,
you're also going
to be not successful
in that regard.
So you have to guess a
fair amount of stuff.
There's no sort
of oracle access.
You can't just query the
server and say, well, what
is that guy's sequence number?
So that's the reason why that
doesn't work out as well.
So again, many of
these issues were
fixed, including
this RST-based thing,
especially for BGP routers.
There was actually two
sort of amusing fixes.
One really shows you
how you can carefully
exploit existing things
or take advantage of them
to fix particular problems.
Here, the insight is
that these routers only
want to talk to each
other, not to someone
else over the network.
And as a result,
if the packet is
coming not from the immediate
router next across the link,
but from someone else, I want to
drop this packet all together.
And what the designers of these
writing protocols realized
is that there's this wonderful
field in a packet called time
to live.
It's an 8-bit field that gets
decremented by every router
to make sure that packets
don't go into an infinite loop.
So the highest this TTL
value could ever be is 255.
And then it'll get
decremented from there.
So what these writing
protocols do--
it's sort of a
clever hack-- is they
reject any packet with a
TTL value that's not 255.
Because if a packet
has a value of 255,
it must have come
from the router
just on the other
side of this link.
And if the an adversary
tries to inject any packet
to tamper with this
existing BGP connection,
it'll have a TTL
value less than 255,
because it'll be decremented
by some other routers
along the path,
including this one.
And then it'll just get
rejected by the recipient.
So this is one example
of a clever combination
of techniques that's
backwards compatible
and solves this very
specific problem.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't the
bottom right router
also send something
with a TTL of 255?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so these
routers are actually--
this is a physical router.
And it knows these
are separate links.
So it looks at the TTL
and which link it came on.
So if a packet came
in on this link,
it will not accept it
for this TCP connection.
But you're right.
For the most part,
these routers trust
their immediate neighbors.
It need not necessarily
be the case.
But if you keep
seeing this problem,
and you know you've
implemented this hack,
then it must be one
of your neighbors.
You're going to look.
TCP dumped these interfaces.
Why are you sending me
these reset packets?
This problem is not as big.
You can manage it by
some Auto Pan mechanism.
Make sense?
All right, there are
other fixes for BGP
where they implemented some
form of header authentication,
MD5 header
authentication as well.
But they're really targeting
this particular application
where this reset attack
is particularly bad.
This is still a problem today.
If there's some
long-lived connection
out there that I really
want to shoot down,
I just have to send some
large number of RST packets,
probably on the order
of hundreds of thousands
or so, but probably
not exactly 4 billion.
Because the servers
are actually somewhat
lax in terms of which sequence
number they accept for a reset.
It can be any packet
within a certain window.
And in that case, I could
probably, or any attacker,
reset an existing
connection with a modest
but not a huge amount of effort.
That's still a problem.
And people haven't really found
any great solution for that.
All right, and I guess the
sort of last bad thing that
happens because these
sequence numbers are somewhat
predictable is
just data injection
into existing connections.
So suppose there is some
protocol like rlogin,
but maybe rlogin doesn't--
suppose we have some
hypothetical protocol
that's kind of like rlogin,
but actually it doesn't do
IP-based authentication.
You have to type
in your password
to log in, all this great stuff.
The problem is once you've
typed your password,
maybe your TCP connection
is just established
and can accept arbitrary data.
So wait for one of you guys
to log into a machine, type
in your password.
I don't know what
that password is.
But once you've
established TCP connection,
I'll just try to guess
your sequence number
and inject some data into
your existing connection.
So if I can guess your
sequence numbers correctly,
then this allows me
to make it pretend
like you've typed some command
after you authenticated
correctly with your password.
So this all sort of
suggests that you really
don't want to rely on these
32-bit sequence numbers
for providing security.
But let's actually see what
modern TCP stacks actually
do to try to mitigate
this problem.
So as we were sort
of discussing,
I guess one approach that
we'll look at in the next two
lectures is how to
implement some security
at the application level.
So we'll use cryptography
to authenticate and encrypt
and sign and verify messages
at the application level
without really
involving TCP so much.
But there are some
existing applications
that would benefit from
making this slightly better,
at least not make it so easy
to exploit these problems.
And the way that
I guess people do
this in practice today-- for
example Linux and Windows--
is they implement the suggestion
that John gave earlier,
that we maintain
different initial sequence
numbers for every
source destination pair.
So what most TCP SYN
implementations do
is they still compute this
initial sequence number
as we were computing before.
So this is the old
style ISN, let's say.
And in order to
actually generate
the actual ISN for any
particular connection,
we're going to add a
random 32-bit offset.
So we're going to include
some sort of a function.
Think of it like as like
a hash function like SHA-1
or something maybe better.
And this is going to be
a function of the source
IP, the source port
number, the destination IP
address, destination port,
and some sort of a secret key
that only the server
knows in this case.
So this has the
nice property that
within any particular
connection,
as identified by a source
and destination IP port pair,
it still preserves all
these nice properties
of this old style sequence
number algorithm had.
But if you have connections from
different source/destination
tuples, then there's
nothing you can
learn about the exact value
of another connection tuple's
sequence number.
And in fact, you'll have
to guess this key in order
to infer that value.
And hopefully the server,
presumably the OS kernel,
stores this key
somewhere in its memory
and doesn't give it
out to anyone else.
So this is how pretty
much most TCP stacks
deal with this
particular problem
today to the extent allowed
by the total 32-bit sequence
number.
It's not great,
but sort of works.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat that again?
Is the key unique to--
PROFESSOR: So when
my machine boots up,
or when any machine boots up,
it generates a random key.
Every time you reboot it
it generates a new key.
And this means that
every time that
for a particular
source/destination pair,
the sequence numbers
advance at the same rate as
controlled by this.
So for a given
source/destination pair,
this thing is fixed.
So you observe your
sequence numbers
evolving according to
your initial sequence
numbers for new connections
evolving according
to a particular algorithm.
So that still provides all these
defences against old packets
from previous connections being
injected into new connections,
just like packet
reordering problems.
So that still works.
And that's the only
real thing for which
we needed this sequence
number choosing algorithms
to prevent these duplicate
packets from causing problems.
However, the thing that
we were exploiting before,
which is that if
you get the sequence
number for one connection
from A to S, then
from that you can infer
the sequence number
for a different connection.
That's now gone.
Because every connection
has a different
offset in this 32-bit space as
implemented by its F function.
So this completely decouples
the initial sequence numbers
seen by every connection.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the point
in including the key?
PROFESSOR: Well, if you
don't include the key,
then I can connect to you.
I'll compute the same function
F. I'll subtract it out.
I'll get this.
I'll compute this function F
for the connection I actually
want to fake.
And I'll guess what the initial
sequence number for that one
is going to be.
AUDIENCE: So can you--
because machines now restart
infrequently, can you still
[INAUDIBLE] by reversing--
PROFESSOR: I think
typically this function F
is something like a
cryptographically secure hash
function, which has a
semi-proved property that it's
very difficult. It's
cryptographically
hard to invert it.
So even if you were given the
literal inputs and outputs
of this hash function
except for this key part,
it would be very
hard for you guess
what this key is
cryptographically,
even in an isolated setting.
So hopefully this will be at
least as hard in this setting
as well.
We'll talk a little bit more
about what these functions
F are a bit later on and how
you to use them correctly.
Make sense?
Other questions of this
problem and solution?
All right, so in
fact, this was mostly
sort of an example of these
TCP sequence number attacks
that aren't as relevant anymore.
Because every operating system
basically implements this plan
these days.
So it's hard to infer
what someone's sequence
number is going to be.
On the other hand, people
keep making the same mistakes.
So even after this was
implemented for TCP,
there was this other
protocol called
DNS that is hugely vulnerable
to similar attacks.
And the reason is that DNS
actually runs over UDP.
So UDP is a stateless
protocol where you actually
don't do any connection
establishment where
you exchange sequence numbers.
In UDP, you simply
send a request
from your source
address to the server.
And the server figures out what
the reply should be and sends
it back to whatever source
address appeared in the packet.
So it's a single
round trip, so there's
no time to exchange
sequence numbers
and to establish that,
oh, yeah, you're actually
talking to the right guy.
So with DNS, as a
result, for a while,
it was quite easy to fake
responses from a DNS server.
So how would a query look
like in DNS, typically?
Well, you send some
queries-- so suppose
a client sends a packet from
client to some DNS server
that knows the DNS server's
IP address ahead of time,
maybe preconfigured somewhere,
say, well, here's my query.
Maybe I'm looking for mit.edu.
And that's basically it.
And the server's
destination port number
is always 53 for DNS.
And the clients used to also
run on the same port number
for ease of use or something.
So you send this packet
from the client on this port
to the server on this port.
Here's the query.
And the server eventually
sends back a reply saying,
mit.edu has a particular IP
address, 18.9 dot something.
The problem is that some
adversary could easily
send a similar response
packet pretending
to be from the server.
And there's not a whole
lot of randomness here.
So if I know that you're
trying to connect to mit.edu,
I'll just send a lot of packets
like this to your machine.
I know exactly what DNS
server you're going to query.
I know exactly what
your IP address is.
I know the port numbers.
I know what you're querying for.
I can just supply my
own IP address here.
And if my packet gets
there after you send this
but before you get
the real response,
your client machine is
going to use my packet.
So this is another example
where insufficient randomness
in this protocol makes it
very easy to inject responses
or inject packets in general.
And this is actually
in some ways even worse
than the previous attack.
Because here you could
convince a client
to connect to another
IP address all together.
And it'll probably
cache this result,
because DNS involves caching.
Maybe you can supply
a very long time
to live in this response
saying, this is valid for years.
And then your client,
again till it reboots,
is going to keep using this
IP address for mit.edu.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you fix this
by having the client include
some random value in the
query, and the server customer
exactly?
PROFESSOR: That's right,
yeah, so this is typically
what people have done now.
The problem, as we were sort
of talking about earlier,
is backward compatibility.
It's very hard to change
the DNS server software
that everyone runs.
So you basically
have to figure out,
where can you inject randomness?
And people have
figured out two places.
It's not great.
But basically there's
a source port number,
which is 16 bits of randomness.
So if you can choose the
source port number randomly,
then you get 16 bits.
And there's also
a query ID inside
of the packet, which
is also 16 bits.
And the server does
echo back the query ID.
So combining these
two things together,
most resolvers these days
get 32 bits of randomness
out of this protocol.
And it, again, makes it
noticeably harder, but still
not cryptographically perfect,
to fake this kind of response
and have it be
accepted by the client.
But these problems keep
coming up, unfortunately.
So even though it was
well understood for TCP,
some people I guess suggested
that this might be a problem.
But it wasn't actually fixed
until only a few years ago.
Make sense?
All right, so I guess
maybe as an aside,
there are solutions
to this DNS problem
as well by enforcing
security for DNS
at the application level.
So instead of relying on
these randomness properties
of small numbers of
bits in the packet,
you could try to use encryption
in the DNS protocols.
So protocols like DNS SEC
that the paper briefly
talks about try to do this.
So instead of relying on
any network level security
properties, they require that
all DNS names have signatures
attached to them.
That seems like a sensible plan.
But it turns out that
working out the details
is actually quite
difficult. So one example
of a problem that showed
up is name and origin.
Because in DNS, you
want to get responses.
Well, this name has
that IP address.
Or you could get a response
saying, no, so sorry,
this name doesn't exist.
So you want to sign the it
doesn't exist response as well.
Because otherwise,
that adversary
could send back a doesn't
exist response and pretend
that a name doesn't exist,
even though it does.
So how do you sign
responses that certain names
don't exist ahead of time?
I guess one possibility
is you could
give your DNS server the key
that signs all your records.
That seems like a bad plan.
Because then someone who
compromises your DNS server
could walk away with this key.
So instead, the model the
DNS SEC operates under
is that you sign all your names
in your domain ahead of time,
and you give the signed
blob to your DNS server.
And the DNS server can then
respond to any queries.
But even if it's compromised,
there's not much else
that that attacker can do.
All these things are
signed, and the key
is not to be found on
the DNS server itself.
So the DNS SEC protocol had this
clever mechanism called NSEC
for signing nonexistent records.
And the way you would do
this is by signing gaps
in the namespace.
So an NSEC record might
say, well, there's
a name called foo.mit.edu, and
the next name alphabetically
is maybe goo.mit.edu.
And there's nothing alphabetical
in between these two names.
So if you query for a
name between these two
names alphabetically
sorted, then
the server could send back
this signed message saying,
oh, there's nothing
between these two names.
You can safely
return, doesn't exist.
But then this
allows some attacker
to completely enumerate
your domain name.
You can just ask for some
domain name and find this record
and say, oh, yeah, great.
So these two things exist.
Let me query for gooa.mit.edu.
That'll give me a
response saying,
what's the next name in
your domain, et cetera.
So it's actually
a little bit hard
to come up with
the right protocol
that both preserves all
the nice properties of DNS
and prevents name enumeration
and other problems.
There's actually
a nice thing now
called NSEC3 that tries to solve
this problem partially-- sort
of works, sort of not.
We'll see, I guess, what
gets it [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any kind of signing
of nonexistent
top level domains?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
think actually yeah.
The dot domain is
just another domain.
And they similarly have this
mechanism implemented as well.
So actually dot and dot
com now implement DNS SEC,
and there's all these
records there that say, well,
.in is a domain
name that exists,
and dot something else exists,
and there's nothing in between.
So there's all these things.
AUDIENCE: So other
than denial of service,
why do we care so
much about repeating
domain names within mit.edu?
PROFESSOR: Well,
probably we don't.
Actually, there's
a text file in AFS
that lists all these
domain names at MIT anyway.
But I think in
general, some companies
feel a little uneasy
about revealing this.
They often have
internal names that
sit in DNS that should never
be exposed to the outside.
I think it's actually this
fuzzy area where it was never
really formalized what
guarantees DNS was providing
to you or was not.
And people started
assuming things like, well,
if we stick some name, and it's
not really publicized anywhere,
then it's probably secure here.
I think this is another place
where this system doesn't have
a clear spec in terms of
what it has and doesn't
have to provide.
And when you make some
changes like this, then people
say, oh, yeah, I was
sort of relying on that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
replay attack
where you could send
in bold gap signature?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
there's actually
time outs on these things.
So when you sign this,
you actually sign and say,
I'm signing that
this set of names
is valid for, I
don't know, a week.
And then the clients, if they
have a synchronized clock,
they can reject old
signed messages.
Make sense?
All right, so this is on the
TCP SYN guessing attacks.
Another interesting problem that
also comes up in the TCP case
is a denial of
service attack that
exploits the fact that the
server has to store some state.
So if you look at
this handshake that we
had on the board
before, we'll see
that when a client establishes
a connection to the server,
the server has to actually
remember the sequence number
SNC.
So the server has to
maintain some data structure
on the side that says,
for this connection,
here's the sequence number.
And it's going to say, well,
my connection from C to S
has the sequence number SNC.
And the reason the server
has to store this table
is because the server
needs to figure out what
SNC value to accept here later.
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] SNS?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the server
also needs SNS I guess, yeah.
But it turns out that--
well, yeah, you're right.
And the problem is that--
actually, yeah, you're right.
SNS is actually
much more important.
Sorry, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] SNS is actually
much more important.
Because SNS is how
you know that you're
talking to the right guy.
The problem is that
there's no real bound
on the size of this table.
So you might get packets
from some machine.
You don't even know who sent it.
You just get a packet that
looks like this with a source
address that claims to be C.
And in order to potentially
accept a connection later
from this IP address, you have
to create this table entry.
And these table entries
are somewhat long lived.
Because maybe someone is
connecting to you from a really
far away place.
There's lots of packet loss.
It might be not for maybe
a minute until someone
finishes this TCP handshake
in the worst case.
So you have to store this
state in your TCP stack
for a relatively long time.
And there's no way
to guess whether this
is a valid connection or not.
So one denial of service
attack that people discovered
against most TCP stacks
is to simply send
lots of packets like this.
So if I'm an attacker, then I'll
just send lots of SYN packets
to a particular server and
get it to fill up its table.
And the problem is
that in the best case,
maybe the attacker just
always uses the same source IP
address.
In that case, you
can just say, well,
every client machine is allowed
two entries in my table,
or something like this.
And then the attacker can use
up two table entries but not
much more.
The problem, of course,
is that the attacker
can fake these
client IP addresses,
make them look random.
And then for the
server, it's going
to be very difficult to
distinguish whether this
is an attacker trying to
connect to me or some client
I've never heard of before.
So if you're some website that's
supposed to accept connections
from anywhere in the world, this
is going to be a big problem.
Because either you deny
access to everyone,
or you have a store state
for all these mostly fake
connection attempts.
Does that make sense?
So this is a bit of a
problem for TCP, and in fact
for most protocols that
allow some sort of connection
initiation, and the
server has to store state.
So there's some fixes.
We'll talk about
in a second what
workaround TCP implements to
try to deal with this problem.
This is called SYN
flooding in TCP.
But in general,
this is a problem
that's worth knowing
about and trying
to avoid in any protocol
you design on top as well.
So you want to make sure
that the server doesn't
have to keep state
until it can actually
authenticate and identify,
who is the client?
Because by that time, if you've
identified who the client is,
you've authenticated
them somehow,
then you can actually
make a decision,
well, every client is
allowed to only connect
once, or something.
And then I'm not going
to keep more state.
Here, the problem is
you're guaranteeing
that you're storing state
before you have any idea who it
is that is connecting to you.
So let's look at
how you can actually
solve this SYN flooding attack
where the server accumulates
lots of state.
So of course, if you
could change TCP again,
you could fix this pretty
easily by using cryptography
or something or changing exactly
who's responsible for storing
what state.
The problem is we
have TCP as is.
And could we fix this problem
without changing the TCP wire
protocol?
So this is, again, an exercise
in trying to figure out, well,
what exactly tricks
we could play
or exactly what assumptions
we could relax and still
stick to the TCP header
format and other things.
And the trick is to in fact
figure out a clever way
to make the server
stateless without having
to-- so the server isn't
going to have to keep
this table around in memory.
And the way we're
going to do this
is by carefully choosing SMS.
Instead of using this formula
we were looking at before, where
we were to add this
function, we're
instead going to
choose this sequence
number in a different way.
And I'll give you
exactly the formula.
And then we'll talk about why
this is actually interesting
and what nice properties it has.
So if the server detects that
it's under this kind of attack,
it's going to switch
into this mode
where it chooses SNS using
this formula of applying
basically the same or
similar kind of function F
we saw before.
And what it's going
to apply it to
is the source IP, destination
IP, the same things as before,
source port, destination
port, and also timestamp,
and also a key in here as well.
And we're going to concatenate
it with a timestamp as well.
So this timestamp is going
to be fairly coarse grained.
It's going to go in
order of minutes.
So every minute, the
timestamp ticks off by one.
It's a very coarse grained time.
And there's probably some split
between this part of the header
and this part of the header.
This timestamp doesn't
need a whole lot of bits.
So I forget exactly what this
protocol does in real machines.
But you could easily
imagine maybe using 8 bits.
For the timestamp,
I'm going to be
using 24 bits for this chunk
of the sequence number.
All right, so why
is this a good plan?
What's going on here?
Why this weird formula?
So I think you have to
remember, one was the property
that we were trying to achieve
of the sequence number.
So there's two things going on.
One is there's this defense
against duplicated packets
that we were trying to achieve
by-- maybe the formula is still
here.
Nope-- oh, yeah, yeah, here.
Right, so just to
compare these guys-- so
when we're not under
attack, we were previously
maintaining this old style
sequence number scheme
to prevent duplicate packets
from previous connections, all
this good stuff.
It turns out people
couldn't figure out
a way to defend against these
kinds of SYN flooding attacks
without giving up
on this property,
so basically
saying, well, here's
one plan that works
well in some situations.
Here's a different plan where
we'll give up on that ISN
old style component.
And instead, we'll
focus on just ensuring
that if someone presents us this
sequence number S in response
to a packet, like
here, then we know it
must've been the right client.
So remember that in order to
prevent IP spoofing attacks,
we sort of rely
on this SNS value.
So if the server sends this
SNS value to some client, then
hopefully only that client can
send us back the correct SNS
value, finish establishing
the connection.
And this is why you had to store
it in this table over here.
Because otherwise,
how do you know
if this is a real response
or a fake response?
And the reason for using
this function F here
is that now we can maybe not
store this table in memory.
And instead, when a connection
attempt arrives here,
we're going to
compute SNS according
to this formula
over here and just
send it back to whatever client
pretends to have connected
to us.
And then we'll forget all
about this connection.
And then if this third packet
eventually comes through,
and its SNS value here matches
what we would expect to see,
then we'll say, oh
yeah, this must've
been someone got our
response from step two
and finally sent it back to us.
And now we finally
commit after step three
to storing a real entry for
this TCP connection in memory.
So this is a way to sort of
defer the storage of this state
at the server by requiring
the server, the client,
to echo back this exact value.
And by constructing it
in this careful way,
we can actually check
whether the client just
made up this value, or if it's
the real thing we're expecting.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SNC [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so SNC now,
we basically don't store it.
It's maybe not great.
But so it is.
So in fact, I guess
what really happens
is in-- I didn't show it here.
But there's probably going to be
sort of a null data field here
that says this
packet has no data.
But it still includes the
sequence number SNC just
because there's a field for it.
So this is how the
server can reconstruct
what this SNC value is.
Because the client is going
to include it in this packet
anyway.
It wasn't relevant before.
But it sort of is relevant now.
And we weren't going to
check it against anything.
But it turns out to be
pretty much good enough.
It has some unfortunate
consequences.
Like if this is-- well,
there's some complicated things
you might abuse here.
But it doesn't seem
to be that bad.
It seems certainly
better than the server
filling up its memory and
swapping serving requests
all together.
And then we don't include
in this computation.
Because the only thing
we care about here
is offloaded the
storage of this table
and making sure that the only
connections that eventually you
do get established are
legitimate clients.
Because therefore,
we can say, well,
if this client is establishing
a million connections to me,
I'll stop accepting
connections from him.
That's easy enough, finally.
The problem is that all
these source addresses,
if they're spoofed,
are hard to distinguish
from legitimate clients.
Make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would you need
to store the timestamp?
PROFESSOR: Ahh, so the
clever thing, the reason
this timestamp is sort
of on the slide here,
is that when we receive this
SNS value in step three,
we need to figure
out, how do you
compute the input
to this function F
to check whether it's correct?
So actually, we
take the timestamp
from the end of the packet,
and we use that inside
of this computation.
Everything else we
can reconstruct.
We know who just sent us
the third step and packet.
And we have all these fields.
And we have our key, which
is, again, still secret.
And this timestamp just comes
from the end of the sequence,
from the last 8 bits.
And then it might
be that we'll reject
timestamps that are too old,
just disallow old connections.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm guessing
the reason you only
use this when
you're under attack
is because you lose 8 bits
of security, or whatever?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's not great.
It has many bad properties.
One is you sort of lose 8 bits
of security in some sense.
Because now the
unguessable part is just
24 bits instead of 32 bits.
Another problem is what happens
if you lose certain packets?
So if this packet is lost--
so it's typically, in TCP,
there's someone responsible
for retransmitting something
if a particular packet is lost.
And in TCP, if the
third packet is lost,
then the client might not
be waiting for anything.
Or sorry, maybe
the protocol we're
running on top of
this TCP connection
is one where the
server is supposed
to say something initially.
So I connect.
I just listen.
And in the SMTP, for
example, the server
is supposed to send me some
sort of an initial greeting
in the protocol.
So OK, suppose I'm
connecting to an SMTP server.
I send my third packet.
I think I'm done.
I'm just waiting for
the server to tell me,
greetings as an SMTP server.
Please send mail.
This packet could get lost.
And in real TCP, the
way this gets handled
is that the server from step
two remembers that, hey, I
sent this response.
I never heard back,
this third thing.
So it's the server
that's supposed
to resend this packet
to trigger the client
to resend this third packet.
Of course, if the server
isn't storing any state,
it has no idea what to resend.
So this actually makes
connection establishment
potentially
programmatic where you
could enter this weird
state where both sides are
waiting for each other.
Well, the server
doesn't even know
that it's waiting for anything.
And the client is
waiting for the server.
And the server basically
dropped responsibility
by not storing state.
So this is another
reason why you
don't run this in production
mode all the time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Presumably also you
could have data commissions
if you establish two very
short-lived connections right
after each other
from the same host.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely,
yeah, yeah.
So another thing is, of
course, because we gave up
on using this ISN
old style part,
we now give up
protection against
these multiple connections
in a short time period being
independent from one another.
So I think there's a
number of trade-offs.
We just talked about three.
There's several more
things you worry about.
But it's not great.
If we could design a protocol
from scratch to be better,
we could just have a separate
nice 64-bit header for this
and a 64-bit value for this.
And then we could
enable this all the time
without giving up the
other stuff and all
these nice things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just had one
quick question on the SNS.
In step two, [INAUDIBLE],
do they have to be the same?
PROFESSOR: This
SNS and this SNS?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
because otherwise,
the server has no way to
conclude that this client got
our packet.
If the server didn't check that
this SNS was the same value as
before, then these actually
would be even worse.
Because I could fake a
connection from some arbitrary
IP address, then
get this response.
Maybe I don't even
get it, because it
goes to a different IP.
Then I establish a connection
from some other IP address.
And then the server
is maintaining
a whole live connection.
Probably a server crosses
another side waiting for me
to send data and so on.
AUDIENCE: But the timestamp is
going to be different, right?
So how can the
server recalculate
that with a new timestamp
and null the one before
if it doesn't store any state?
PROFESSOR: So the way this
works is these timestamps, as I
was saying, are course grained.
So they're on a
scale of minutes.
So if you connect
within the same minute,
then you're in good shape.
And if you connect on the
minute boundary, well, too bad.
Yet another problem
with the scheme-- it's
imperfect in many ways.
But most operating
systems, including Linux,
actually have ways of detecting
if there's too many entries
building up in this table
that aren't being completed.
It switches to this
other scheme instead
to make sure it doesn't
overflow this table.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if the
attacker has control
of a lot of IP addresses,
and they do this,
and even if you
switch it the same--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
then actually there's
not much you can do.
The reason that
we were so worried
about this scheme
in the first place
is because we wanted to
filter out or somehow
distinguish between the
attacker and the good guys.
And if the attacker
has more IP addresses
and just controls more
machines than the good guys,
then he can just connect to our
server and request lots of web
pages or maintain connections.
And it's very hard
then for the server
to distinguish whether these
are legitimate clients or just
the attacker tying up
resources of the server.
So you're absolutely right.
This only addresses the
case where the attacker
has a small number
of IP addresses
and wants to amplify his effect.
But it is a worry.
And in fact, today it might
be that some attackers control
a large number of
compromised machines,
like just desktop machines
of someone that didn't
patch their machine correctly.
And then they can just mount
denial of service attacks
from this distributed set of
machines all over the world.
And that's pretty hard
to defend against.
So another actually interesting
thing I want to mention
is denial of service attacks,
but in the particular way
that other protocols
make them worse.
I guess other protocols allow
denial of service attacks
in the first place.
I'm sorry.
But there are some that are
protocols that are particularly
susceptible to abuse.
And probably a good
example of that
is, again, this DNS protocol
that we were looking at before.
So the DNS protocol--
we still have it
here-- involves the
client sending a request
to the server and the server
sending a response back
to the client.
And in many cases, the response
is larger than the request.
The request could be just,
tell me about mit.edu.
And the response might
be all the records
the server has about
mit.edu-- the email address,
the mail server for mit.edu,
the assigned record if it's
using DNS SEC, and so on.
So the query might be 100 bytes.
The response could well
be over 1,000 bytes.
So suppose that
you want to flood
some guy with lots of
packets or lots of bandwidth.
Well, you might
only be able to send
a small amount of bandwidth.
But what you could do is you
could fake queries to DNS
servers on behalf of that guy.
So you only have
to send 100 bytes
to some DNS server pretending to
be a query from that poor guy.
And the DNS server is going
to send 1,000 bytes to him
on your behalf.
So this is a problematic
feature of this protocol.
Because it allows you to
amplify bandwidth attacks.
And partly for
the same reason we
were talking about with
TCP's SYN flooding attacks,
it's very hard for the
server, for the DNS server,
in this case, to know whether
this request is valid or not.
Because there's no
authentication or no sort
of sequence number
exchanges going on
to tell that this is the
right guy connecting to you,
et cetera.
So in fact this is still
a problem in DNS today.
And it gets used
quite frequently
to attack people with
bandwidth attacks.
So if you have a certain
amount of bandwidth,
you'll be that
much more effective
if you reflect your attack
off of a DNS server.
And these DNS servers are
very well provisioned.
And they basically have
to respond to every query
out there.
Because if they stop
responding to requests,
then probably some legitimate
requests are going to get
dropped.
So this is a big
problem in practice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you can still
see it on the DNS server,
[INAUDIBLE] requests
and never reply to--
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah, so
it's possible to maybe modify
the DNS server to keep some
sort of state like this.
AUDIENCE: That's the reason
why this still works now,
because they don't store state?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well
I think some people
are starting to modify DNS
server to try to store state.
A lot of times, there's so
many DNS servers out there
that it doesn't matter.
Even if you appear to do 10
queries against every DNS
server, that's
still every packet
gets amplified by some
significant factor.
And they have to respond.
Because maybe that client really
is trying to issue this query.
So this is a problem.
Yeah, so you're right, if
this was one DNS server,
then this would be maybe
not as big of a deal.
The problem is also that
the root servers for DNS,
for example, aren't
a single machine.
It's actually racks
and racks of servers.
Because they're so heavily used.
And trying to maintain a state
across all these machines
is probably nontrivial.
So as it gets abused
more, probably it
will be more worthwhile
to maintain this state.
I guess a general
principle you want
to follow in any
protocol-- well,
might be a good
principle-- is to make
the client do at least as much
work as the server is doing.
So here, the problem is the
client isn't doing as much work
as the server.
That's why the server can help
the client amplify this effect.
If you were redesigning
DNS from scratch,
and this was really
your big concern,
then it'd probably be fairly
straightforward to fix this.
The client has to
send a request that
has extra padding bytes just
there just wasting bandwidth.
And then the server is
going to respond back
with a response that's
at most as big as that.
And if you want a response
that's bigger, maybe
the server will say, sorry,
your padding wasn't big enough.
Send me more padding.
And this way, you guarantee that
the DNS server cannot be used
ever to amplify these
kinds of bandwidth attacks.
Actually, these
kinds of problems
happen also at higher
levels as well.
So in web
applications, you often
have web services that do
lots and lots of computation
on behalf of a single request.
And there's often denial of
service attacks at that level
where adversaries know that
a certain operation is very
expensive, and they'll
just ask for that operation
to be done over and over again.
And unless you carefully design
your protocol and application
to allow the client
to prove that, oh, I'm
burning at least as much work
as you, or something like this,
then it's hard to defend
against these things as well.
Make sense?
All right, so I
guess the last thing
I want to briefly touch
on about the paper
we talked about as well
is these routing attacks.
And the reason these
attacks are interesting
is they're maybe popping up
a level above these protocol
transport level issues.
And look at what goes
wrong in an application.
And the routing protocol is
a particularly interesting
example.
Because it's often
the place where
trust and sort of initial
configuration gets
bootstrapped in the first place.
And it's easy to sort
of get that wrong.
And even today, there's not
great authentication mechanisms
for that.
Perhaps the clearest
example is the DHCP protocol
that all of you guys use
when you open a computer
or connect to some
wireless or wired network.
The computer just sends
out a packet saying,
I want an IP address
and other stuff.
And some DHCP server at MIT
typically receives that packet
and sends you back, here's an
IP address that you should use.
And also here's a DNS
server you should use,
and other interesting
configuration data.
And the problem is that the
DHCP request packet is just
broadcasting on the
local network trying
to reach the DHCP server.
Because you actually
don't know what
the DHCP is going
to be ahead of time.
You're just plugging into the
network, the first time you've
been here, let's say.
And your client doesn't
know what else to do
or who to trust.
And consequently, any
machine on the local network
could intercept
these DHCP requests
and respond back
with any IP address
that the client could use, and
also maybe tell the client,
hey you should use my DNS
server instead of the real one.
And then you could intercept
those future DNS requests
from the client and so on.
That make sense?
So I think these protocols are
fairly tricky to get right.
And on a global scale,
the protocols like BGP
allow any participant to
announce a particular IP
address prefix for the
world to sort of know about
and route packets
toward the attacker.
There's certainly been attacks
where some router participating
in BGP says, oh,
I'm a very quick way
to reach this particular
IP address range.
And then all the
routers in the world
say, OK, sure, we'll send
those packets to you.
And probably the most
frequent abuse of this
is by spammers who
want to send spam,
but their old IP addresses
are blacklisted everywhere,
because they are sending spam.
So they just pick some
random IP address.
They announce that, oh yeah,
this IP address is now here.
And then they sort of
announce this IP address,
send spam from it,
and then disconnect.
And it gets abused a
fair amount this way.
It's sort of getting less now.
But it's kind of hard to fix.
Because in order
to fix it, you have
to know whether someone really
owns that IP address or not.
And it's hard to do
without establishing
some global database of,
maybe, cryptographic keys
for every ISP in the world.
And it takes quite a
bit of effort by someone
to build this database.
The same actually applies
to DNS SEC as well.
In order to know which
signature to look for in DNS,
you have to have a
cryptographic key associated
with every entity in the world.
And it's not there now.
Maybe it'll get built up slowly.
But it's certainly one big
problem for adopting DNS SEC.
All right, so I guess the
thing to take away from this
is maybe just a bunch of
lessons about what not
to do in general in protocols.
But also actually one
thing I want to mention
is that while probably
secrecy and integrity are
good properties and driving
force of higher levels
of abstraction, like in
cryptographic protocols
in the application-- and we'll
look at that in next lectures--
one thing that you really
do want from the network
is some sort of availability
and DOS resistance.
Because these properties
are much harder
to achieve at higher
levels in the stack.
So you really want
to avoid things
like maybe these
amplification attacks, maybe
these SYN flooding attacks,
maybe these RST attacks
where you can shoot down an
arbitrary person's connection.
These are things that are
really damaging at the low level
and that are hard
to fix higher up.
But the integrity and
confidentiality you
can more or less
solve with encryption.
And we'll talk about how we
do that in the next lecture
on Cerberus.
See you guys then.